oof okay yeah still sticking to these
carry they have not switched ever since
we saw them on stream
so
and back to the twilight conflict
there's something with the stage mark
man i don't know what it is but yeah it
seems like this is where we settle all
the beefs
well are we going to have fox meat or
are we going to have geese meat that's
the question
let's see what happens though chicken
always off to like a slow start so owl
is gonna have to be very careful like he
cannot rest on his laurels if he gets
some rounds in
okay oh nice pickup
good timing there with all four three
and the follow-up here he has the wall
now what's the mix
so far so good on our side but we know
checker and slowly gathering data he's a
download machine he's a monster when it
comes to these type of match-ups he's
probably just getting the timing but
these these lows have been landing so
far for owl
nice punisher he crouched cancelled into
the follow-up knee and now he's gonna
get the full carry into the wall oh he
almost closed it out there
not looking too good for chickering two
rounds straight i was starting to
believe yeah checkering's gonna have to
come up with something or i was gonna
get no round
big launch wow just in the middle of my
sentence oh just yeah putting it all
like all on the line though
that was a huge opportunity there he
missed the combo follow-up but it
doesn't matter he gets the stab
oh my gosh stabby mcstabberson and look
at that ending it with a very convincing
perfect
uh yeah getting away with murder there
excellent three rounds straight so i
mean we were checker and um yeah does
download at the start but
oh giving him nothing there and you know
what this is still a best of three so if
al could pull that same thing off
chicory might not even have time to
download he's gonna have to act and act
quick
bro i didn't think it was gonna be that
one-sided this opening match so i'd like
to see it just here from which i know of
course he probably does have ready but i
feel like the way he was going into the
match when we talk about chicken he's a
wall right sometimes he's just a
defensive wall whether it's throwing out
safe pokes or he's playing very
conservative
he could not handle the offensive
mix-ups the lows the spacing and and the
whip punishes that al had at the ready
so
again he's gonna have to change it up
otherwise we might be seeing more of the
same
yeah that's true it's just
yes you can kind of like try and give a
couple rounds just to collect that data
but i i think at some point like you're
gonna you're gonna have to like all
right
i'm getting i'm getting like cycloned
into this mix-up already i need to learn
how to deal with this i need to deal
with it quick and i think he needs to
just show uh like put it all in the line
now when it comes to this next match
because it's really going to come down
to the wire
and owl ladies and gentlemen mind you ow
actually in the standings is tied with
neuroma they're both at 180 so i just
checked right now so they're both at 180
and al really needs more points on the
board to secure his spot here at the
tekken online challenge for the
regionals at least
well one more match will definitely help
him out in his quest for points and
we're going back to the devil's pit man
twilight conflict in devil's pit have
been the stages that we've been seeing a
lot of today
but every time we've had devil's pit and
you s it usually is the end so is owl
going to get a 2-0 here let's see
chicorin again has to make some
adjustments because right now he's just
watching and guessing wrong against a
lot of iowa's offense but this time
getting a big low parry the follow up
okay collecting some huge damage early
seconds here chickering though
any good read on that low parry but
let's see if he'll still continue owl
yep move the desk gets blocked
okay
and al just knows when to go on the
defense he knows when it's too too um
too dangerous from to press forward nice
sidestep the republican to the the
dagger throw
see final seconds chickering no meter to
work with just yet but does have rage
ow nice punishment
nice i like what i'm seeing here
always really showing that not only is
he putting the offensive mix-ups into
him but he's also putting the brakes
when he needs to to get a punish
[Music]
yeah he's aware he knows when like not
to go tunnel vision and go all offense
and and we saw that in those final
sequence now chicarin
significant life lead in early 15
seconds jumps okay
so far so good the the wall is is
starting to close in with the the wall
known as chickering the defensive wall
is showing up now ow
trying to open them up able to get a few
sequences in but chickering now cash is
in the meter
oh yeah he's gonna close it out nice and
easy
and this is the the first you know match
round that we've seen really go in
chicorin's favor hopefully he'll be able
to continue that momentum especially now
that he has some meter on his side
no duck on the second hand the second
hit is high
ow being more calculated coming into the
approach here he knows the chicken now
um the the more you have matches him the
more he'll find ways but he was able to
snipe him out of the air there and found
the wall
oh he tried to stab him in the face not
able to get it but the downpour two hits
in a crouching state
look at that sidestep he's out of there
yeah now it's chicken into the back
against the wall the one one two to
carry him across cartwheeling on him oh
spends the meter and ow just blocking
all of it
markman look at the time oh my god
throws the kunai
uh-huh
and he's just he's out of there i love
it
i love it
look at that wow he didn't even choose
to push the action just like i'm just
going to duck this and that was a
checkmate situation ow now potentially
yeah one more round and he can send
checker in home no uh walls in this in
this matchup now and al has been getting
away with a lot of these like just
running away with a lot of the the
offense now so can he continue in this
uh fourth round
we'll see i mean he puts him into a
position where chicorin has to act now
he's at a life deficit he's at a round
deficit but this is huge this is a huge
opportunity here
yeah he had to make that one count oh
the movement again followed up oh he was
able to block it in time
oh yeah because of the positioning and
him getting hit back turned he was able
to recover a little bit faster just to
get the block on the floor forward too
big opportunity here he does have rage
he's gonna have to watch out oh he might
be dead he might be dead
wow
he is dead mark man and owl moves on
setting checker in you know out of this
tournament
yeah and you know what it was incredible
more one-sided more one-sided than i
thought it would be but al with a great
performance now chickering getting tied
for fifth place as well and now that uh
lines it up to our loser semi's final
match where we know it's gonna be double
versus ow so we're down to our final
four players
yeah and can i just mention that
double